this video is sponsored by blinkist
here's the link in the description and
you'll receive one free week and 25 off
an annual premium membership
sometimes the story behind a work of art
is just as fascinating as the work
itself
sometimes its origin is part of its
content
the story of 20th century writer
Fernando passoa and his Masterwork the
book of disquiet is one of those cases
where the story behind it sounds like a
work of fiction itself
pasoa was born in 1888 in Lisbon
Portugal at the early age of just five
years old he was exposed to loss and
impermanence when his father died of
tuberculosis and then the following year
his younger brother died
not long after his mother remarried and
his family moved to South Africa also
taking from Fernando the landscape of
his childhood
while living in South Africa basso
became fluent in English and developed
an appreciation for English literature
when he turned 17 he returned to Lisbon
by himself where he would spend the rest
of his life and dedicate most of his
time to writing
however by the time he died in 1935 at
the age of 47 he had only published a
few books that went mostly unnoticed and
he essentially wrote in complete
obscurity Unknown by anyone
but yet he seemingly died knowing that
he was a great literary figure or at the
very least that he would likely become
one
and in an almost unsettling prophetic
way
he was right
after his death pessoa's work the
manuscript of the book of disquiet along
with tens of thousands of other
manuscript pages that are still to this
day being edited remain tucked away in a
wooden trunk Unknown by anyone
it wasn't until 1982 47 years after
pasoa died eerily the exact same age of
pasoa when he died that the book of
disquiet was found and published
this book would go on to become what is
widely regarded as one of the most
unique and important literary works of
the 20th century
inside the book is a lifetime worth of
basoa's Reflections and musings about
reality and dreaming about tedium and
selfhood about the absurdity of being
and the futility of doing about the
simultaneous complexity and simplicity
of Life about the contradiction and
Paradox at the core of everything
the book is made up of a collection of
fragmented vignettes written in a style
somewhere between diary entries and
poetry
there is no real linear order to the
book and it can arguably be experienced
just as well backwards as forwards even
more interesting but SOA does not claim
to be the author of any of it rather it
is credited to a man named Bernardo
Suarez an assistant bookkeeper from
Lisbon Portugal as well as possibly a
man named Vicente gueres
Juarez and soras however aren't real
they are characters pesoa created to
create the book found throughout the
massive collection of all of pasoa's
manuscript pages are various pseudonyms
fictitious authors that he credits
different pages and collections to these
authors aren't just different pen names
though they are different characters
with different writing styles and
personalities and Views and backstories
pasoa referred to these author
characters as heteronims and there were
around 80 that he rode under throughout
his lifetime
thus the book of disquiet is not exactly
a non-fiction book from an anonymous
author but nor is it really a novel
about a fictional character or story it
is somewhere in between
because of this it is often described as
the weirdest autobiography ever written
but SOA himself described it as a
factless autobiography or an
autobiography of someone who never
existed
the book's unique structure and style is
in many ways an essential supporting leg
of the book's themes the use of
heteronim seems to reinforce a key
philosophical theme throughout the work
the fragmented and illusory nature of
the self with Incredible accuracy and
poignancy that feels cathartic to read
throughout the book but SOA frequently
describes the inherent alienation
disorientation and loneliness associated
with being a person he wrote I don't
know how to feel or think or love I'm a
character in a novel as yet Unwritten
hovering in the air and undone before
I've even existed amongst the dreams of
someone who never quite managed to
breathe life into me I'm always thinking
always feeling but my thoughts lack all
reason my emotions all feeling I'm
falling through a trapdoor through
Infinite Space in a directionless empty
fall my soul is a black Maelstrom a
great Madness spinning about a vacuum
the swirling of a vast ocean around a
hole in the void and in the waters more
like whirlwinds than Waters float images
of all I ever saw or heard in the world
houses faces books boxes snatches of
music and fragments of voices all caught
up in a Sinister bottomless whirlpool
and I I myself am the center that exists
only because the geometry of the Abyss
demands it I am the nothing around which
all this spins I exist so that it can
spin I am the center that exists only
because every Circle has one
for pesoa self-understanding or perhaps
the attempt to understand the self is a
free fall down a rabbit hole with the
landing that kills you and the
impossibility of understanding and
communicating one's internal experiences
while on this free fall lends itself to
a lifetime of disquiet and
disorientation
throughout the book pasoa also often
discusses themes of tedium futility and
meaninglessness for him everything is a
sort of delusion life is a sequence of
Dreams
I've never done anything but dream this
and this alone has been the meaning of
my life my only real concern has been my
inner life but so wrote
verbisoa there is no real point in doing
or achieving anything reality as we
experience it is as deluded and false
and meaningful as the several dreams we
had last night that dissolved upon
awaking never to be known or thought of
again
life is but a dream destined to be coded
over with the fog of Consciousness and
forgotten upon the morning sunrise
pasoa wrote If I write what I feel it's
to reduce the fever of feeling what I
confess is unimportant because
everything is unimportant
the recognition of the futility of doing
anything and the advocation of receding
into a dream world reinforces another
major theme of the book contradiction
and paradox
after all why write about the
pointlessness of doing anything and the
impossibility of ever adequately saying
anything while doing something and
saying things perhaps however this does
not speak to the incoherence of basoa
but rather speaks to what pesoa might
believe is useful in paradox
in medicine certain preventative and
preparation treatments contain forms of
the bacteria or virus that cause the
disease the treatment is used to prevent
likewise arguably both creating and
consuming good literature and good art
expose you to the virus of being so you
can hopefully develop enough immunity to
survive
perhaps paradoxically then the driving
force that compelled pasoa to create and
write and do was the awareness that
creating and writing and doing is
pointless
it is also relevant to note that the
book of disquiet was left unfinished
with this it is almost as if the book
mirrors besoa's philosophical conception
of existence
trapped inside a trunk only truly known
after pasoa's death once it could no
longer be changed by him interpreted
only through a fragmented collection of
vignettes written by someone who never
existed finished by time not by
intention the book itself seems to be an
almost perfect metaphor for a person
it is unsettling to consider all of this
and then realize that the word pesoa his
birth name translates in English into
person
if that's not enough perhaps the most
confounding aspect of the book of
disquiet story is that it contains
passages that prophesize its fate
in it pesoa wrote it sometimes occurs to
me with sad Delight that if one day in a
future I won't be part of the sentences
I write are read and admired then at
last I'll have my own kin people who
understand me my true family and which
to be born and loved but far from being
born into it I'll have already died long
ago I'll be understood only in effigy
when affection can no longer compensate
for the indifference that was the Dead
Man's lot in life perhaps one day
they'll understand that I fulfilled like
no one else my instinctive duty to
interpret a portion of our century and
when they've understood that they'll
write that in my time I was
misunderstood that the people around me
were unfortunately indifferent and
insensitive to my work and that it was a
Pity this happened to me and whoever
writes this will fail to understand my
literary counterpart in that future time
just as my contemporaries don't
understand me
because men learn only what would be of
use to their great grandparents the
right way to live is something we can
teach only the Dead
and of course all of this came true
it's happening right now with these
words
we are currently participating in
pasoa's Fortune told by himself a
century ago
one can only Wonder was this a
masterfully constructed plan by a genius
creative mind was it chance was it both
or was it something else
whatever the case may be the story of
the book of disquiet seems to have
almost become a part of its artistic
creation
it elicits an almost metaphysical
spiritual quality it feels like a
religious book for atheists a manual for
nihilists it can and probably will
devastate most of those who read it
but it will also help comfort and remind
one to not take oneself or life too
seriously
sometimes exposure to the ailment is
part of the treatment
this video was sponsored by blinkist
Samantha was never a great reader it
wasn't that she didn't like reading or
value books she did but she always
struggled with sustaining the habit and
carving the time out of her day to read
on average she read about one to two
books every year maybe three if she was
lucky
one year however suddenly everything
changed Samantha went from learning from
two to three books to learning from 67
books in one year more books than her
entire life prior but yet she didn't
spend any more time than she had any
previous year
Samantha was able to make this dramatic
shift and satisfy her goal to read and
learn more while not interfering with
the regular schedule by discovering and
using the app blinkist when her best
friend Chrissy noticed how much more
well-read Samantha suddenly seemed
Chrissy asked Samantha what was going on
Samantha told Chrissy about blinkist
explaining that it condenses over 5 500
non-fiction books and podcasts across a
ton of different categories into around
15-minute explainers that you can both
read or listen to even while offline
Samantha told Chrissy that she often
listened to blinkist's insights about
books while on her morning walk her
commutes and while she did errands and
chores on the app she showed Chrissy the
title conscious by Annika Harris a book
that Samantha had been meaning to read
but hadn't had the time to get to
Samantha told her how she learned a ton
of new ideas about the nature of
Consciousness like how conscious
perception is really not the driver of
most of what happens in the brain and is
likely the last part to know about the
brain's decisions
Samantha also told Chrissy about
Blanca's curated Collections and guides
that she had been using to better
develop her critical thinking and
creativity for work
when Chrissy said she wanted to get
blinkist herself using a feature called
blinkus connect Samantha was able to
share her account with one other person
and the two began to use the app and
share their favorite books together at
no additional cost
if you're interested in creating the
same strong habit for yourself this new
year by using the link in the
description or by scanning the QR code
on the screen you'll receive one free
week of unlimited access to blankest as
well as 25 off an annual premium
membership the free 7-Day trial can be
canceled at any time within the trial
period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video